you
if you just work for money you'll never
make it but if you love what you're
doing success will be yours ray kroc
I want to make a million dollars before
I turn X years old sounds familiar most
new entrepreneurs are just trying to
make money and that's why they fail
you're tired of working for someone else
and think you can strike it rich by
branching off on your own you're partly
right if you look at any list of the
world's wealthiest people and remove
those who have inherited well almost
everyone else is an entrepreneur you
don't make real money working for
someone else but and this is a huge but
if money is your only goal then you'll
never be rich look at the list of the
most successful entrepreneurs and you'll
see that none of them are given by the
money they want to change the way
something is done they want to have an
impact they want to leave a legacy to be
successful as an entrepreneur you need
to build a business around your passion
and use your one word as your operating
philosophy you're not running a charity
here unless you are money is important
you're here to create profits and wealth
but it's not the most important thing
success leaves clues still don't believe
that money should never be a primary
goal here are some more examples to
follow I encourage you to look up your
favorite entrepreneur and see how they
got started and what their priorities
work Richard Branson said never go into
business purely to make money if that's
the sole motive you're better off doing
nothing Chris Gardner said you have to
be committed and you have to find
something that you are passionate about
and forget about money Joyce Clyde hall
said if a man goes in the business with
only the idea of making a lot of money
chances are he won't but if he puts
service and quality first the money will
take care of itself produced in the
first class product it is a real need is
a much stronger motivation for success
rich oprah winfrey said what i know is
is that if you do work that you love and
work that fulfilled you the rest will
come and i truly believe that the reason
i've been able to be so financially
successful is because my focus has never
ever for one minute been money while
disney said disneyland is a work of love
we didn't go into disneyland just with
the idea of making money Donald Trump
said the most important thing in life is
to love what you're doing because that's
the only way you'll ever be good at it
money was never a motivation for me
except as a way to keep score the real
excitement season playing the game and
jennifer lopez said if you focus on the
money you're not going to get anywhere
you can want to be successful but at the
end of the day if money is your
motivation if that's how shallow your
outlook is on life then you're going to
be such an empty person because there's
nothing driving you from the inside
there's no passion
you